come on
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
leeches are something like a combination
of a science fiction monster movie and
uh like little vampires they survive by
feeding on the blood of humans and other
animals they have 10 sets of eyes but
poor eyesight and they can go six months
or more without feeding
when leech is attached to their host
they pierce the skin with long probiscus
and inject a blood thinning
anticoagulant the host rarely feels the
bite because the leech also has very
small and sharp teeth in an anesthetic
in its saliva that numbs the area that
it pierces around the skin
once they lock on they continue feeding
until they've consumed up to five times
their body weight in blood
the largest leaked species is the giant
Amazon leech which can grow over 18
inches long and four inches wide
I know it sounds strange but Physicians
have been using leeches in a variety of
medical procedures for thousands of
years and Incredibly hospitals still
order them today for doctors to use in
healing everything from eczema to
promote circulation in micro surgery
well Pastor Carlos who would ever think
these slimy little vampire worms could
have a Positive Purpose yeah it reminds
me in the Bible of Sometimes some
uncomfortable situation that God uses to
to bring some healing into our lives
right yeah and you know sometimes a
person might think that they're just not
good enough but God uses Sinners that
are transformed to do a great work amen
which reminds me of a verse that Paul
shares in First Corinthians chapter 1
verse 26
for you see your calling Brethren that
not many wise according to the flesh not
many mighty not many noble are called
but God has chosen the foolish things of
the world to put to shame the wise and
God has chosen the weak things of the
world to put to shame the things that
are Mighty and the base things of the
world and the things that are despised
God has chosen and the things that are
not to bring to nothing the things that
are that no flesh should glory in his
presence the Lord can even use little
worms and he can use us that's uh that's
a lesson in humility which makes me
think about the ultimate condescension
is when Jesus the king of the universe
creator of all things comes to Earth and
becomes a creation that'd be like you
and I becoming a worm when you are even
less than that yeah
and uh you know the there's a lot of
beautiful lessons in the Bible about the
humility of Christ and how he laid aside
his glory and came into this world and
if you'd like to know more about that
and how God can use you Jesus is an
example that he humbled himself and God
did great things and he can do great
things through you we have a free offer
that we'd like to make available yes
that free offer is called down from his
glory down from his glory there's two
ways you can receive it you can call us
at
1-800-835-6747 uh ask her offer 154 or
give the title or you can also using
your mobile phone you can dial pound 250
on your mobile device and say Bible
answers live and you will be able to
obtain this free gift this is only in
the United States since free shipping is
in the United States U.S territories and
Canada only
um and while we're at it might as well
give a good greetings to those tuning in
on First Light TV in New Zealand hope
Channel worldwide as well as mktv in
Michigan so amen we've got a lot of
stations that air the program live
Sunday evening and some of you may be
listening to a rebroadcast and a variety
of stations both TV and radio the TV
audience is actually growing and that's
it's very exciting if you are watching
on TV you notice that Pastor Ross's
voice sounds a little different tonight
that's because we have Pastor Carlos
he's been in here with us many times
Pastor Carlos is the director of our
evangelism training program better known
as AFCO amazing facts centers of
evangelism
and also leading out in the amazing
facts Latino work amen so any questions
in Spanish tonight no don't do that to
us
but why don't you have prayer for us
Pastor Carlos before we begin let's pray
father we thank you for just a beautiful
opportunity that you give us to open
your word and spend time with those
people that may have questions in their
minds just help them Father so that they
can get connected with us and that you
give us the discernment and your wisdom
so that it will be your answers and
perfect harmony with your word for your
glory and so we thank you for this
opportunity and we ask this in Jesus
name amen amen
all right the first question we have is
from Isabella calling us from Texas
hello Isabella you're on Bible answers
live
hello
um I was wondering what are the best
evidences for the Earth being created in
like six literal days and what does the
Bible say about scripture being literal
yeah well uh I think it's clear in the
context when God talks there in Genesis
chapter one and two about the days of
creation and I think the Hebrew word is
Yum the days of creation being 24-hour
periods because they're given
sequentially it says the evening and the
morning it also tells us God does not
make the Sun the moon and the stars
until the fourth day yet he's made the
vegetation on the third day if these
were not literal days well you know
plant can live for a few days without
sunlight but they can't live for a few
ages or millennia
and the light that God has when he first
says let there be light it's just the
light of his glory his presence
the Bible says that God is light so are
there several scriptures that said in
six days the Lord created the heavens
and the Earth it's also repeated in the
Sabbath command and just all through the
scriptures God reiterates that he made
the world in six days and it's it's
never set forth as ages or epics of some
reform fun fact too is where did uh the
seven day week cycle come from yeah all
around the world every nation has a
seven day week and you can find reasons
in astronomy for a 365 day year is what
it takes for the earth to circle the sun
you find reasons for most calendars
having a 30-day month that's a lunar
cycle
there's no reason for a seven day week
and yet the world all carries out a
literal seven-day week thank you and
that's just a start is uh
we've got a book called the wonders of
creation and it may address that
question Isabella
thank you thank you
all right next we have ash from Florida
first time caller Ash welcome to Bible
answers live
thank you yes sir and your question
my question is
what should a Christian do to mature
their relationship with God they've been
in the church for a long time but they
still keep Commandments for
Health preservation
that's really a great question and we
appreciate your asking that Ash there's
a lot of people out there and they're
kind of going to church out of
obligation now there's nothing wrong
with you know when a person first comes
to the Lord to be doing it because
you're trying to avoid trouble and you
want to go to heaven
you know when we first start teaching
children
sometimes you have to start with some
pretty basic motives you know if they
disobey there's sometimes pain or
there's a reward for doing something
right but as those children mature
you're hoping that they're going to
learn to obey their parents because they
love and trust their parents and know
that what they're asking in principle is
a good thing when we start out following
the Lord you know the Bible says repent
lest you perish it's normal to not want
to perish and Jesus tells about the
reward for the righteous to desire those
things as normal I mean even the
disciples said Lord what will we get
and they want to know what's our reward
we left everything to follow you so
there's nothing wrong with that but as
you mature ultimately a Christian needs
to be motivated by love
the Bible says we love him because he
first loved us so the key Ash is that we
might learn to love him more and we read
about Christ's love for us the better we
know him the more we love him so through
reading the word through communion with
God we fall in love with a person
because you talk to them
we get to know him better we love him
more we want to serve him better it
usually boils down to the three
Christian disciplines of reading the
word
um
prayer
and then being a witness as you lead
others to Christ you find real joy in
that amen so yeah and you know we have
some booklets that talk about how you
can have a better relationship with the
Lord actually there's that book called
the drummer boy's prayer and if you read
that Ash I think it'll really encourage
you it's called the drummer boy's prayer
amen just a reminder of offers
1-800-835-6747 for those offers thank
you very much Ash next we have Jerry
calling us from Texas welcome Jerry
you're on the air
hey guys hi pastors I just didn't want
to get your take on this my question is
like in a way a two-part question but
I'm gonna maybe phrase it rephrase it in
one part I haven't uh Joshua 5 13-15
where you have Joshua meeting
the angel of the Lord before he took on
Jericho and then also we have Abraham in
the Bible he walked with God when he
gave God a meal and before if Sodom and
Gomorrah was destroyed and then we have
Jacob
that uh wrestled with God
and then after uh I think this is the
fourth time that you had the situation
Manoa in Judges 13 15 to 20 when uh
her and her husband meant the angel of
the Lord
and uh but no Moses only saw the
backside of God and he was probably more
Godly than others well Abraham was Godly
so to summarize your question
oh
why would why did Moses not get the
get Lord as is Abraham or Jacob or
Joshua these others
yeah that's a good question uh there's a
verse and Pastor Carlos might have it
more at his fingertips where it says no
man has seen the father at any time and
Moses we believe uh he had seen God
probably every bit as good or as well I
should say as Joshua or Manoa or Jacob
when Jacob wrestled he said I have seen
God they saw what we call a christophany
they saw a human incarnation of Christ
where Christ came and he peered to
Abraham he appeared to Joshua he
appeared to Jacob but they were not
seeing God In His glory
and what Moses was asking and it's funny
you would mention this pastor Carlos and
I just before we went on the air we're
talking about Moses wanting to see the
glory of God so that's very strange that
you should ask that right now and but
when Moses was on the mountain he was in
the presence of the Lord for 40 days
twice so you know 80 Days up in the
mountain in The Cloud of Glory
but he hadn't really seen the
undiminished presence of the almighty
unveiled I should say
because the Bible says no man can see
God his even God said no man will see
his face in our mortal condition we
cannot endure it
um in heaven we will you read in
Revelation and they will see his face we
will see him face to face in our
glorified purified condition you find
that verse yep John 6 46 not that any
man had seen the father save he is
theirs of God how he has seen the father
so only Jesus says so they probably saw
what they call a pre-incarnation
appearance of Jesus
that's why Jesus said Abraham saw my day
and he embraced it
thank you appreciate that Jerry
next we have Judith Judith from Nevada
welcome your own Bible answers live
hello hi Pastor Carlos ambassador
okay pastor Carlos
Venezuela Foster dogs
anyway thanks for taking my call my
question is in the lands of the great
controversy between Christ and Satan we
know that the Christ is the head of his
body who now on the side of the enemy
who is the body of the serpent
is it in the context of the kingdom of
Babylonia in the in the um perspective
of the Old Testament and the kingdom of
Jerusalem is the kingdom of God all
right perspective thank you for
answering yeah we'll do our best I think
what's Happening Here is when Jesus said
you know Christ is ahead of his church
the body is the bride of Christ the
people of Christ but there's another
people there's only two groups in the
world there's those that are on the
straight road to Salvation and those on
the broad road to destruction Jesus said
if you're not with me you're against me
you're either part of the bride of
Christ or you're part of the children of
Babylon as you mentioned junip and
there's several titles Jesus said to the
religious leaders you are of your father
the devil
so the whole world is really divided
into those either surrendered to Christ
or not
they even know the Lord and they've
accepted the Plan of Salvation or not
and you know there might be some
well-intentioned people
that are on the wrong road and that's
why we've got to let them know but yeah
that would be the the body or the Bride
of the devil
you've got two women in Revelation
Revelation 12 you've got the bride of
Christ Revelation 17 you've got the
Bride of the Beast so to speak
thank you Judith appreciate your call
next we have Gary from Illinois Gary you
are on the air welcome
oh thank you Christians as a group they
should be taking climate change
seriously it's the most pressing problem
facing Humanity those that do
this is my question uh will they be
wearing the crown of those people who
you know drive hybrid cars and plant
trees and recycle I mean that's what
that's what the church should emphasize
and that's you know the Earth's gods and
so that releases us from any uh you know
responsibility
okay that's my question okay well you
know certainly there are blessings and
benefits in every believer being
responsible stewards
uh in many capacities and one of course
being of the world you know God gave
Adam and Eve the world and he said that
they were to dress and attend the garden
they were to keep and take care of
things and uh but uh there's no
salvation
in being environmentally
careful because I've got some dear
friends that are very sensitive about
the environment
but they don't accept Christ and so
they're not going to be saved because
they drive a hybrid car they you know
there's there's no salvation in saying
I'm going to plant a tree
and of course there are people who claim
to be Christians that are not saved
because their lives don't reflect the
principles of Christ but you know while
there may be wonderful benefits and
blessings in being responsible stewards
of the planet nobody's saved by that
salvation comes only through surrender
to Christ and making them the Lord of
your life amen it reminds me of
Revelation 11 18 it says that uh God is
going to destroy those that destroy the
Earth right but not because the Earth is
God came to save it but because you're
making the situation for everybody else
that lives here you're causing harm on
other humans polluting the air polluting
the water but you can't say I'm just
following up on what you're saying while
it is true God is destroying those that
destroy the Earth he is not saving those
that save the Earth yeah oh yeah yeah so
you know it's uh well yeah it might
sound like a double negative but
hopefully that made sense thank you very
much appreciate your call Gary thank you
Gary next we have Cindy from California
welcome to Bible answers live
thank you good evening Pastor Doug and
Pastor Carlos good evening my question
is how do you do how do you determine
what are okay activities to do on the
Sabbath when I was a kid
we were allowed to sit on the couch and
read the junior guide
for my example is it is it okay to
cook for potluck and play in the snow
which we just got a lot of this week in
Southern California
can you swim I mean how do you determine
what is okay and what's not good you
know and I don't often mention it but
amazing facts does carry a book I wrote
a little book as we get this question a
lot as being pastors now what's a good
way to how do you keep the Sabbath holy
and anyone out there if you want you can
call and request that how do we keep the
Sabbath holy
um but let me give you some quick
principles you know when folks say you
shouldn't be cooking on the Sabbath well
you need to back these things up with
scripture or at least scriptural
principles Moses told the children of
Israel gather your Manna ahead of time
there'll be no Manna on Sabbath bake
what you're going to bake boil what
you're going to boil and that would mean
as far as possible you'd want to get all
of your cooking done you know there's
some things that just for the
practicality of it you might need to
still do in food preparation so you can
present it in a helpful fresh way on
Sabbath but you should get all of the
cooking you possibly can done out of the
way because it's a day of rest if you're
doing all the work of every other day it
sort of loses the blessing of rest and
freedom when it comes to getting out in
nature that's a wonderful thing you know
if you're walking up a trail and the
kids kids on a summer they want to cool
their feet in the creek that's great
but you know I'm a parent it can turn
into a swimming party pretty quick and
you know as soon as they say well okay
if I can get in my up to my ankles can I
get in up to my knees the next thing
they're doing cannonballs off the rocks
and having plain water polo so you know
you just you have to have some
boundaries or things can get out of hand
you know after church even at our church
the kids all get outside and they've got
ants in their pants and they want to run
around that's fine but then I saw them
the other day they brought a soccer ball
I said ah guys let's put that away it's
not supposed to turn into a a World Cup
game
so um you just need to pray you can you
know have wisdom and not a discern yeah
and I remember the story in Mark 3 when
Jesus heals a guy with a dry hand yeah
he says it's good to do good on the
Sabbath right sure yeah so heal people
visit people get out in nature Bible
studies yeah
there's there's even I think some
appropriate games you could play with
your kids that would like teach them
Bible memory or something so you keep
their minds engaged that's the big
challenge is often with the kids the
adults have no problem sleeping taking a
nap literally with the kids they want to
get out and do something you got to have
some good activities yeah and you have
to plan it right yeah you can't you have
to plan during the week what am I gonna
how am I going to get my kids to be
excited about this exactly you don't
want to start remembering the Sabbath
Friday evening you want to remember on
Sunday Monday Tuesday yeah or make the
Sabbath everything about no you can't do
this no no no no but they're delighting
in it right you want them to be excited
when it comes and sad when it goes amen
amen
all right thank you very much Cindy next
we have Anthony from New York Anthony
you are on the air welcome
yes good evening Pastorius good evening
I'm gonna say something in Spanish one
of the previous callers beat me to it
but uh
Pastor Doug knows Spanish don't be
surprised
good stuff it's a little bit yeah
I'll try to make my question as brief as
possible um I'm gonna give a little
short background but
um so Hezekiah was considered to be a
righteous King I know um and uh
I think uh chapter 18. but then in
second Kings chapter 20 I will see the
Lord uh through the prophet Isaiah that
he was going to
die he and and verse two he says he
turned his face to the wall and prayed
unto the Lord verse 3 says he wept sword
yes God to let him live
so uh God did allow him to live and he
left for another 15 years
but unfortunately he ended up marring
his witness as a result of living longer
and so emotion is
um you know we sometimes have loved ones
or even ourselves we may be sick unto
death right terminal illness so when
should we pray fervently or bitterly as
Hezekiah did and ask God for healing and
to let us live and when should we accept
impending death as his will and that he
might just be protecting us from
something in our future yeah that's a
good question uh you know we often as
pastors go and you pray by the bedside
of somebody that is sick we have
occasional anointing services and pray
for their healing but whenever we do
that we should always say thy will be
done you know that's in the Lord's
Prayer
um thy will be done on Earth as it is in
heaven should be a daily prayer in every
situation I think the normal thing for
us to do is to pray for healing that's
why the Bible commands us is anyone sick
call together the elders pray that they
might be healed Jesus went around
healing and so God wants us to pray for
healing for a full life now that doesn't
mean I had a sister in our church so
when she got to be uh you know like 93
she's a pastor Doug I want you to come
pray for my healing
I said well I can do that but I said
first let me ask do you think there's a
connection between your hearing issues
and being 93 she gave me a big smile she
said you telling me I'm getting old I
said I didn't say that
but you know at some point uh life sort
of runs its course
and I think most of the healing that you
see in the Bible is to give a person a
normal life
uh you know a normal lifespan
um and when people are in the final ages
and stages of life
then you commit them to God's care you
can always ask them to lengthen his
train a lengthen their tranquility and
give them a little more time for some
reason but
always say thy will be done amen
hey thank you appreciate that Anthony
we have Frank from New York Frank
welcome to Bible answers live here on
the air
Carlos my question for both of you uh
both gentlemen is of the following
I I don't understand uh what where it
says in Scripture that a person who's
not baptized and who believes they're
saved and they're uh a Christian who
believes in in God and the Holy Bible
cannot really be lived throughout life
and enter the kingdom of God without
being baptized is that scripturally
correct or do you have to live with
baptism to actually believe in scripture
because when I was a child an infant I
was baptized and then I never believed
in God after that until they forced me
to believe in receiving a uh and you
cannot mention religions over the on
your show but they re they forced me to
receive a uh a form of
question Adoration of God through his
second level of of sacramental life so
can you live without baptism throughout
your entire life
without baptism all right let's talk
about that good question first of all uh
but what's the answer this way e Frank
there will be some people in heaven that
were not baptized clearly because well
the thief on the cross next to Christ he
couldn't be baptized Jesus said you'll
be with me I think Christ gave him
credit for his baptism
and then you've got all these Old
Testament characters that will be in
heaven they didn't practice baptism all
through the Old Testament so for those
living in the New Testament times it's
pretty clear that baptism is like a
marriage
between a believer in Christ and Jesus
says in Mark chapter 16 and you might
jot this down e Frank Mark chapter 16
verse 16 he who believes and is baptized
will be saved
he who does not believe will be
condemned notice he puts a pretty high
priority On Believing in being baptized
but then he adds he that does not
believe he doesn't say and is not
baptized will be condemned believing is
the big emphasis but when Jesus sent out
the apostles he said go teach in all
nations baptizing them in the name of
the father Son and Holy Spirit and then
Peter preaching at Pentecost in Acts
chapter 2 when they said men and
Brethren what shall we do to be saved he
said repent and be baptized for the
remission of sins
ananiah said to Paul arise and be
baptized and wash away your sins calling
on the Lord so all through the New
Testament there's a great deal of
emphasis on baptism and that's not the
baptism that an infant would received
because that's not Bible baptism it's a
decision you make as an adult to follow
the example of Jesus have your sins
washed away to be filled with the Holy
Spirit and commit your life to him you
need to be able to believe repent be
taught and babies can't do these things
you are technically you're dedicated as
a baby
Jesus was dedicated as a baby but he
wasn't baptized till he was 30. he did
that as an adult so technically e Frank
you probably never were really baptized
though that's the term that's used a lot
of people call that baptism it's really
a dedication you need to make the
decision to be baptized all right that's
all the time we've got for this segment
of questions we're coming back in just a
moment don't go anywhere more Bible
questions on their way and you can still
call in for the second half of the
program
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor this
morning my wife Karen sent me on a
mission she said when you're taping your
announcements this morning tell people
about my favorite amazing facts app it's
called The Amazing Facts radio app you
simply type that in amazing facts radio
you can download the app and you can
listen to good Christian music Bible
reading sermons all day long keep your
faith focused in heaven through the day
check it out if you haven't done it yet
the amazing facts radio app you'll be
blessed
go into all the world and preach the
gospel to Every Creature through radio
television print Evangelistic events and
the internet amazing facts International
is heeding the call of Jesus to go into
all the world millions of individuals
and over 150 countries have been blessed
by the word of God amazing facts have
spawned new spheres of influence in
India Africa China and Indonesia with
each new country come hundreds of
translated booklets study guides and
video presentations produced in each
region for the people of that region
armed with these precious truths gospel
workers are empowered to spread bright
rays of light on every path they travel
please visit
reachtheworld.amazingfacts.org to learn
more about amazing facts International
and how you can participate in this
exciting soul-winning Ministry that
website again is reach the
world.amazingfacts.org thank you for
your support
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor it's
time to make your plans and mark your
calendars to attend our third annual
amazing facts youth conference the dates
are June 7th through the 10th 2023. this
year's Mission and title is called
identity change by beholding come and
learn how to turn your focus from the
world to the word and make some great
friends along the way for more
information about the speakers and how
you can register go to afyouth.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and as you can tell from
the title this is a live International
interactive Bible study you are invited
to participate you can not only listen
call your friends now tell them to
listen in we get all kinds of great
Bible questions from around the world if
you have a question just give us a call
it's a free Call of course 800 God says
and that acronym plays out to
800-463-7297 we're also streaming and
beaming on AF TV you can watch this on
the amazing facts Facebook Channel
mace in fact YouTube Doug Batchelor
Facebook so we're trying to use every
medium we can my name is Doug Batchelor
I am Carlos Munoz
and so we want to welcome everybody just
remember if free offers
1-800-835-6747 or dial pound 250 for any
free offers that you hear us give out
let's go back to the phone lines we have
Ruth calling us from North Carolina
hello Ruth you are on the air
oh hi
um good evening Pastor dog and Pastor
Carlos may God bless your ministry we
always pray and support your ministry so
we are thankful for both of you all of
you
um I have a question regarding Mark 16
19. and that question is I thought Jesus
I studied a 2300 day prophecy but I
always get confused because I believe
Jesus to be in the most holy place
um and um after he ascended to Heaven
according to Mark 16 9 he says he sat at
the right hand of God and I thought the
right hand of God meant the most holy
place and I was like I always had the
idea according to scripture that he went
to the holy place and then in 1844
according to the 2300-day prophecy he
went through the holy to the most holy
to clean the cleanse the sanctuary so
that's where my confusion is I don't
know you guys understand my question I
know I do I think your question makes
sense uh first let me give you a couple
of thoughts uh when Jesus first ascended
to Heaven following his sacrifice when
it was declared successful and effective
remember he told Mary do not cling to me
this is John 20 I believe he said don't
cling to me for I've not yet ascended to
my father
but go and tell my brother and I Ascend
my God your God my father your father
When Jesus ascended and he sat down that
meant he was enthroned as Victorious
over the devil and ransoming recapturing
our planet that had been hijacked so to
speak and so there was an enthroning
that happened immediately upon his
Ascension that doesn't mean that his
work as our high priest in the first
apartment of the Heavenly Sanctuary that
first phase was obscured in some way and
I think we've got to kind of defuse
ourselves of the idea that Jesus was
somehow handcuffed in one room of this
heavenly Temple for 2000 years or that
the father couldn't see him because
there's a veil or something between them
the Bible says the veil is removed in
Christ and while Christ is still in his
first role of ministry doesn't mean he
can't see the father he's in the
presence of God in the Heavenly Dwelling
Place this heavenly Sanctuary but the
Heavenly Sanctuary is so infinitely more
Majestic and bigger than the model they
had here on Earth
so yeah he's in the presence of the
glory of the father he went into a final
phase of that Ministry in 1844 when the
age of laodicea began and is still there
now and he'll soon stand up say it is
finished and that's when
things get hairy and scary on earth and
the plagues fall yeah oh by the way and
I was just looking in Acts chapter seven
notice it says in in First Peter he's
gone into heaven he's uh he is at the
right hand of God
uh Mark says he's sitting at the right
hand of God Luke 7 says being full of
the Holy Spirit Stephen gazes into
heaven he saw the glory of God Jesus
standing at the right hand of God right
hand is a sign of favor a sign of
strength it doesn't mean that Jesus is
consigned to one side of the Lord yeah
an intercession too which is ongoing
until he returns he ever lives to make
intercession for us thank you good
question truth
good evening Sophia you are on Bible
answers live welcome
good evening Pastor Doug good evening
Pastor Carlos I wanted to find out um
there's a verse proverbs 18 and verse
21.
then life are in the power of the tongue
now I've heard many interpretations
saying that we can speak things over our
lives like if I lie about being sick
then I can become sick because I spoke
it over my life or
I can speak
bad things over my life but is this what
the verse is saying
you know I don't think that's the
principal meaning of the verse I think
Solomon is talking about that our words
can give life or death
um you know there's a and he also talks
about the power of a king you know like
Nebuchadnezzar he would speak and
someone was executed he'd speak someone
else was promoted
and that was in the power of the tongue
James tells us that the tongue is
extremely powerful and you know it can
set a forest on fire so to speak of
trouble
but the words that you speak carefully
this is also in Proverbs a word fitly
spoken is like apples of gold in
pictures of silver
and so what it says that life and death
is in the power of the tongue you can
speak words of encouragement and Life to
people and hope Jesus he gave life in
his tongue
pilate gave death when he declared him
to be condemned now there is some truth
Jesus said be it unto you according to
your faith it is often true that you
know if people are are negative and they
don't believe sometimes they get what
they don't believe that doesn't mean
that we get to choose what's going to
happen by speaking things but you got to
be careful what you say because you can
be influenced by your own words Christ
talks about uh you know it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy be it unto you
according to your faith so I do think
Christians should be positive and I do
think that we should try to be
encouraging and remember that we are
affected by our own words but this verse
I think is really talking about just the
power of speech for good or evil yeah in
Matthew 12 37 says for by your words you
will be justified and by your words you
will be condemned good point yeah of
course thank you Sophia next we have
Tammy from Washington wait pardon me
Pastor Carlos we have a booklet and it's
called
um it's called tiny tail bears and it's
about the tongue yes power of the tongue
and we'll send you a free copy we don't
often get that uh request but we do have
a good sermon book on that and just a
reminder for offers
1-800-835-6747 or your mobile phone dial
pound 250 and say Bible answers live
next we have Tammy from Washington
you're on Bible answers live welcome
Tammy
hello Pastor Doug and Pastor Carlos hi
um I have an interesting question
um I know in heaven that when we're you
know when we come down to the new Earth
we're going to be building our own
houses we're going to be growing our own
food we're going to be tending animals
well my question relates to the last
part of that I want to know our our
beloved pets that we have here on Earth
going to be in heaven with us that's a
great question and don't feel don't feel
like it's an odd question we actually
get that question probably two or three
times a year which is understandable
because people love their pets and
there's nothing wrong with that in fact
the Bible says a righteous man regards
the life of his beast but The Tender
Mercies of the wicked are cruel
righteous people care about their
animals and the Bible tells us even in
the Ten Commandments it says that on the
Sabbath your ox and your Dome monkey
shall rest God cares about them resting
in the Book of Jonah God says to Jonah
you you don't care about the ninevites
dying what about all the animals in the
city don't you care about them
so um you know God loves animals he's
the one that made them originally Adam
and Eve were to not only tend the garden
but they were to befriend all of the
creatures they would be wonderful
friends and and uh the Delight of Adam
and Eve you give a kid a puppy and
you'll see what I'm talking about
so
um God understands and then we build
relationships you know with our animals
and I like you I'm assuming Tammy have
had you know pets and dogs and cats that
you grow attached to and you love and
their lives are not as long as ours and
and then you lose them and it's so sad
you think we'll ever see him again
I can't tell you about a scripture that
says God is going to resurrect our pets
but I also can't tell you he won't
so we may be very surprised when we get
to the kingdom to find out that God has
given spot and our our kitty little
glorified bodies and raise them we don't
know that the one thing I will promise
nobody in heaven is going to be
disappointed
so just get there God said there's
things you can't even imagine that he
has for those that love them but I can't
point you to a scripture that says he's
going to resurrect our pets thank you
thank you next we have Marvin calling us
from Montreal Canada welcome Marvin
you're on the air
good evening uh Pastor Luke and Pastor
Carlos evening
um my question is about uh
Isaac sorry from English
Isaiah 57 verse 1 and 2. I just want to
more explanation about this verse
yeah all right let's read it for our
listeners it says in Isaiah 57 verse 1
and 2 the righteous perishes and no man
takes it to heart merciful men are taken
away while no one considers that the
righteous is taken away from Evil he
shall enter into peace and they shall
rest in their beds each one walking in
his uprightness
well you know in the time of Isaiah
there was a lot of War they were also
facing the Babylonians that were going
to eventually come and destroy the city
Isaiah foretold that but they were being
attacked also from the Assyrians in the
north uh Isaiah lived and prophesied
during the reign of three kings and a
couple of them were not very good
Hezekiah was good his son was not good
Manasseh and Isaiah is saying you know
no one considers that the righteous
people are being taken away and why is
this happening some of the righteous
were being laid in their graves so they
would not Witness
the terrible things that were going to
come upon the kingdom especially during
the long reign of Manasseh
and sometimes God lays a person in their
grave not as a judgment but as a
blessing to spare them from some plague
and just before the Lord comes there
will be some that I think will be laid
to their rest that they're spared from
the seven last plagues
amen so thank you Marvin's appreciate
that
appreciate your call next we have a from
Australia Joanne Joanne is calling us
welcome to Bible answers live here on
the air
hi Hi how are you good thank you Joan
and your question Joan
my question tonight
um
is
did God's hand intervene
and put the blessing um to put the
blessing on Jacob and not Esau because
Isaac was thinking of his stomach
yeah well I think that um
God actually blessed Jacob because he
had predetermined that Jacob was more
interested in the spiritual blessing
than the monetary one usually the
firstborn son you know Jacob and Esau
were twins but Esau was slightly older
so technically he got a double portion
of his father's Goods
but Jacob knew that it was foretold the
Messiah was going to come through the
descendants of Isaac's father Jacob
wanted this spiritual blessing the proof
of this is that after the years that
Jacob spent away from home he came home
he gave like 10 of everything he owned
to his brother he wasn't interested in
his father's inheritance he was
interested in the spiritual blessing and
that's why he manipulated his uh brother
into selling him the birthright and then
he tricked with the help of his mother
he tricked his father into blessing him
um the idea of Isaac eating before he
blessed him was a custom I don't think
it's because Isaac was you know
preoccupied with his stomach they often
had a feast before they had a covenant
um and that was very common even Jesus
they had a last supper at the time of
the New Covenant
so the Passover was a feast connected
with a covenant I I'm you know Isaac
probably was hungry and he loved a
special kind of food but I don't think
he could say that that's why Isaac I'm
sorry Jacob got the blessing yeah but
good question Joan and by the way where
in Australia are you calling from
what part of the country is that
yep close to the very
Queensland oh okay very good we just got
back from uh Pastor Ross and I were in
Melbourne in Brisbane and then on to New
Zealand so
I think Pastor uh Carlos was heading
back to Australia later this year yeah
I'll be there in April yeah come see him
yeah I wanted
to do yeah I don't blame you well thanks
so much for calling we appreciate it God
bless
next we have David from here in
California David welcome you're on Bible
answers live
hey thanks for taking a call Pastor Doug
Carlos and thanks for the show really
appreciate it
question might about the dead and the
first resurrection so it says the dead
well no not it says when Jesus come
Archangel all will hear his voice the
dead will rise first so
does so will the dead basically have
died three times or the dead just hear
him coming but they gotta stay in the
ground in the pit
what happens to the unrighteous
yeah well the unrighteous are you know
that you die the first death but then
the Bible says the unrighteous are
raised in Judgment at the end of the
1000 years they're then judged because
they're not in the Book of Life they are
cast into the Lake of Fire and the Bible
says in Revelation 20 this is the second
death now the only ones that might
experience a third death so to speak
are well a couple of categories one if
Jesus had risen someone from the dead
and then they died lost then they get
resurrected again judge and die again so
they die three times and then the the
people that are judged or that were
judging Jesus like the high priest
um he's going to be raised to see Christ
come then he'll die again at the second
coming then he's raised at the end of
the Millennium judged and thrown in the
Lake of Fire that would be those who
executed Christ that says those that
pierced him and Christ said you will see
the son of man coming on the right hand
of power
so this but that's a very small group of
people most people that are lost they
just experienced the second death yes
and that versus Matthew 26 verse 64.
about kiephus yeah thank you appreciate
that David good question all right next
we have Jackie Jackie from Arizona
Jackie may still be on the the Lions
here she's over here okay
uh let's see yep here we go Diane from
British Columbia welcome to Bible
answers live you're on the air
thank you now you may be on a
speakerphone get real close to your
phone because you sound far away
that's good I have
oh don't ask that question sir no that's
a good question we're just not sure it's
a difficult subject go ahead I'll let
you finish I interrupted you yeah I was
just wondering about who is the king
King of the South
all right Pastor Carlos you want to take
your first stab at it this is one of the
most hotly debated subjects among
theologians and uh but what we'll share
with you uh some of the ideas that are
out there yes definitely go ahead you
can get started so there's two kings in
Daniel 11 at the end in verse 40 the
King of the North and the King of the
South we know that literally the King of
the North would represent Babylon the
King of the South will represent Egypt
uh Sodom as it's mentioned in the Book
of Revelation so we know the King of the
North would represent the Babylonian
system power that appears in the Book of
Revelation as the end time religious
order and then the King of the South
there's two main interpretations in
regards to the south of representation
of the immorality in the world the
secular world
that'll be combating as we see it today
in society and still to the end and then
there's another interpretation I know
John Ross Falls in line with this is
that the South represents Islam coming
and battling against Christianity too so
yeah and I'm inclined that's I guess I
being that way and I don't you know this
is something that as Paul said we don't
say by command but by permission
you see that the King of the North and I
would agree with Carlos is sort of
apostate Christianity Babylon
and but there are two children of
Abraham that are tracked Through the
Bible we see Islam in earlier places in
Revelation 9 and it is the second
largest religion in the world and there
have been numerous Wars and there's
conflict today and the Nations that are
mentioned in the end of of Daniel if you
being literal at all Edom Moab Libya
Egypt so forth they're all Islamic
principally and so you just wonder if
there'll be some final Earthly conflict
along with the spiritual conflict so uh
some of that remains to be seen but uh
that's those are a couple of principal
views out there and thank you Diane hope
that made a little bit of sense
thank you Diane next we have uh we have
a Raymond from Michigan Raymond welcome
to Bible answers live you're on the air
hello pastors how are you both doing
tonight wonderful
that's good that's good thank you uh my
question is
anywhere and does it where does it does
it say what type or what kind of
language where we where we be speaking
in heaven
all right Pastor Carlos is probably
going to say Spanish is the language of
Heaven yes yes I've heard that before
and uh it is a whole lot easier to learn
than English from what I understand yeah
because I grew up speaking English it
was easier for me but when I learned
some Spanish because the rules were much
more consistent yeah and you know you've
actually taught in English and Spanish
so you've probably run into all of the
conundrums uh but I don't think we'll
speak either in heaven there's some
language all the languages of the world
somehow spring from a mother tongue that
was spoken in the Garden of Eden
and at the Tower of Babel that language
got confounded now you can find
similarities between a number of
languages around the world so as the
people scattered from the Tower of Babel
they took some maybe common words
but um
we don't know exactly which of that
language of Canaan is going to be yeah
but it'll be beautiful I've always
thought it might be Hebrew because when
it says in the in the Tower of Babel it
says he confused the tongues of those
that were working in the tower so could
it be that Hebrew was the original
language Seth and some of his followers
did not Hashem rather and some of his
followers did not get involved in the
corruption and their language did not
get confound that's an interesting
theory that that may be Chris it's sure
hard to speak Hebrew got a lot of kind
of
anyway but uh yeah it'll be uh you know
they say one reason that English is an
international language is over the years
English has developed so many words to
describe things there are more words in
English yeah to describe things with
greater detail
and I think the language of Heaven is
going to have all kinds of nuances we
don't even know now to say things so
it's going to be very beautiful and very
expressive yes whatever it is amen thank
you good question
next we have Nathan from California
Nathan welcome to Bible answers live
here on the air
hello
hi all right
how should I respond to people that say
biblical the Bible is it trustworthy
because it was written by men because
we're travelable and stuff like you know
yeah
well I would say is there anything that
men do that they Trust
just because the Bible was written by
men I mean if if you uh get into a car
accident you've got to go to the
hospital and you've got to have your
legs set you're probably not going to
try and set your broken leg yourself
you're going to have to entrust that to
men and you're going to say well they've
studied it and they've passed on a lot
of knowledge and they can do that pretty
well
because men do something doesn't mean
that it's all flawed all the technology
we're using right now has been created
by men and most of it's pretty
dependable
now with the Bible it wasn't normal men
the Bible says holy men spoke as they
were moved by the Holy Ghost these are
unusual people that are filled with the
Holy Spirit and so the holy spirit is
involved in also preserving the Bible
there's some ways we know that the Bible
is still accurate is God arranged for
scriptures to be hidden before Christ
was born about 200 years before Christ
was born hidden in the desert
and then 2000 years later those
scriptures are rediscovered and we
compare These Old Testament scriptures
that had been hidden in jars the Dead
Sea Scrolls for 2000 years with the
versions of the Hebrew Bible that we
have today and we see that they're
virtually identical and it just
increases our uh and I've been to see
the Dead Sea Scrolls and and had my
guide who spoke ancient Hebrew read
right off of them and I know my Bible
pretty well and he was reading right off
the scroll of Isaiah the story of
Hezekiah and Seneca ribbon the RAB Shack
and it's just like my Bible amen so of
course he had to translate it as he read
it into English but yeah the Bible has
been miraculously preserved yeah do we
have a resource yeah we've got a book
called the um
ultimate resource it's on the Bible
we'll send you a free copy the ultimate
resource just ask for that when you call
Nathan thank you yes we can get one more
question in Pastor yes we can Peyton
from California welcome first time
caller your own Bible answers live
hello good evening pastors good evening
hello
so my question is uh what are the signs
of the second coming and would it be
soon due to the current morality of the
world and I say it as kind of a two-part
question because I am in the military
and I'm kind of stuck in a sense and I
would like to pick up and move on to
country living but it seems quite
difficult considering you know
everything going on in current society
and in your opinion yeah well don't go
don't go AWOL Peyton but
um yeah you know there are a lot of
signs and as you mentioned one of them
is the morality you know Jesus said
before he comes it'll be like it was in
the days of lot in Noah and there was
violence you know people are all
entertained with violence and not only
he said there'd be wars and rumors of
wars we've got rumors of nuclear war
right now uh they would have the
immorality that they had in Sodom and
Gomorrah which is of course you know
International and rampant right now
and then Christ said the gospel of the
Kingdom would be preached in all the
world well now through the internet and
radio and television satellite we have
the technology that human walls cannot
stop the proclamation of the Gospel even
these broadcasts right now through the
internet are going into so many
different countries
and the gospel is being preached in all
the world and so there's a number of
signs that the Lord gives us that his
coming is near one of them is he says
they'll be pestilence that's a place we
just came through a global pandemic and
so you know what it says in Revelation
the Euphrates river will dry up of
course there's a spiritual application
to that but I think it's interesting the
Euphrates river is driving yeah right
now so it might be a dual prophecy there
anyway Peyton so there's a lot of things
you just put your life in God's hands
and say Lord I want to put you first and
uh I'd like to live in the country of
course country living is not going to
save you
having a beautiful place in the country
and food stored away is not going to
save us in the last days it'll be a lot
easier than those who are stuck in the
cities and you know Bedlam breaks out
but ultimately God can save you the
safest place to be is in the middle of
his will and friends I hope everyone
listening is in the hollow of his hand
right now as you can hear our program's
up for tonight go to the website
amazingfacts.org share all those
Resources with your friends and we'll
study his word together with you again
next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
welcome back listening friends for those
who stayed by this is the time we do
some quick internet questions that came
in and Pastor Carlos if someone wants to
send us a question how do they do that
you can email us at
b-a-lquestions at amazingfacts.org
that's b-a-l questions at
amazingfacts.org and we will we might
read your question on live next year
next week let's see how many we can get
in in two minutes here first one during
Noah's time did God limits man's
lifespan to 120 years because Noah lived
to be 950. no it's saying When God says
my spirit will not always strive with
man and this is Genesis chapter 6. his
days will be 120 years that means Before
the Flood God was going to give them 120
years of probation people live much
longer than that even after the flood so
that's not talking about their lifespan
it was talking about probationary time
before the flood yes next question where
were Joseph and Mary married when Mary
conceived Jesus no they were what we
would would call engaged they had signed
a betrothal covenant and Joseph was
about to break that off because he
thought that Mary had come up pregnant
from normal means and God said don't do
it she's conceived by the Holy Spirit
but they were engaged they were not
married yet
next question is it a sin to be rich
well it could be for some people Jesus
said that it's hard for a rich man to
enter the kingdom and the Bible says
strive not to be rich that should not be
our goal but certainly there are a
number of rich people in the Bible that
we expect to see in heaven everyone from
Abraham to Solomon to David to job you
just don't want to love riches the Bible
says the love of money is the root of
all evil Ezekiel 39 11 talks about fire
descending from Heaven to destroy the
Wicked the question is will there be a
cemetery in the new Earth or is this
prophecy already fulfilled in the past
well that is a future prophecy when god
reigns fire down from heaven to Devour
the wicked and then you read it says
that the in Malachi chapter 4 the wicked
will be burnt up root and Branch so all
over the face of the Earth where the
wicked are consumed Malachi says you'll
go forth from the New Jerusalem you will
tread down the wicked they will be ashes
Under The Souls of your feet so I guess
you could say that there's a it's kind
of a cremation all over the world but
it's going to be grass the meek will
inherit the Earth last question was
Jesus like any other regular child
yeah good question in the sense that he
did need to learn to walk and talk as
babies do he needed his parents to love
and cleanse him and he had to learn to
do things that children do yes he never
sinned he never disobeyed he was filled
with the Holy Spirit from his mother's
womb all right listening friends time's
up God bless look forward to studying
with you next week
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions